>> Okay, I think we'll make a start.
And thank you very much for coming, everybody.
Very pleased to welcome Dan Gardner here,
who is going to talk about
his book which is called "Risk: The Science
and Politics of Fear."
Dan is here -- if I've understood it correctly
-- this morning to tell
us that the things we are scared about are
actually the most safe, and
the things that we think are safe are the
most risky.
So to demonstrate this Dan has promised that
he's going to exit the
building today by a bungee jump into a pool
of molten lava, so we all
look forward to that.
Just a very quick word on the at Google program.
In case you haven't been to an at Google talk
before, there are only
about five of us who do this, who put these
talks on.
And we are always looking for volunteers,
so if you're interested in
any aspect of putting these sorts of talks
on, on the communications or
the technical side, please come talk to me
or Lucinda or any of the
others who you may know on the team.
Anyway, enough of that.
Please welcome Dan Gardner.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN GARDNER: Thanks very much.
For the record, bungee jumping is quite safe.
I hope you're all in a good mood because I'm
going to spend the next
hour talking about all the horrible things
that can happen to you.
And so I'll begin with this horrible thing.
Breast cancer.
Yes, I'm going to start by depressing you
--
[INAUDIBLE SPEAKER]
DAN GARDNER: Oh, it's not showing up here?
[PAUSE]
DAN GARDNER: Okay.
Improvise.
How does one do that?
Right. Yeah, so I'm going to start about talking
about something
depressing.
The talk will not be entirely depressing.
I promise you.
In fact, it will get upbeat at a certain point.
I'm going to start with this depressing topic
of breast cancer.
It's a very -- there we go.
There we go.
Obviously, breast cancer is a major issue.
It has been for literally decades.
There have been public health campaigns.
There have been enumerable media stories about
breast cancer.
So we should all know the basic facts about
breast cancer, one would
assume, right?
Well, what's one of the most basic facts?
Here's one.
The risk that a woman experiences at particular
ages.
Okay?
This is a really basic question.
At what age is a woman most at risk of contracting
breast cancer?
Very basic stuff.
We should all know this.
So I'll ask for a show of hands.
Is a woman most at risk of contracting breast
cancer in her forties?
Show of hands.
Nobody?
In her 50s?
A lot of people.
In her 60s?
Some more, but a little bit less in her 70s?
Nobody?
80 or above?
One.
Age does not matter?
Everybody else.
And now as you're all clever people, so you
will have surmised that I
begin my talk with this quiz because it always
delivers the results
that I need.
And the results that I need are you're all
wrong.
Except for you. Sir.
There's always one in the audience.
There's always one.
Breast cancer, as with most cancers, the single
biggest risk factor, by
far -- by far is age.
The older a woman is, the more at risk she
is.
It's really that simple.
So the correct answer is 80 or above.
Okay.
Now this is all horribly unscientific, but
I can tell you I've given
this quiz to enumerable audiences in multiple
countries, and I've
always gotten the same response.
I actually once gave this quiz to the Health
Ministry in Canada and got
the same response, which is rather disturbing,
really.
But this is done somewhat more scientifically
by Oxford researchers.
They surveyed British women, and they asked
them this same question.
And in that quiz, 0.7 percent of women got
the answer right to this
most basic question about this most important
issue.
Pretty astonishing, isn't it?
It's a pretty big gap between perception and
reality.
And that's what I'm going to be talking about
today is the gap between
perception, risk perception and risk reality.
Risk perception researchers really got underway
in the 1970s largely in
the United States as a result of the controversy
over nuclear power.
Nuclear engineers said this is safe, the public
said we're worried.
The nuclear engineers said but here are the
numbers.
The public said we are don't care about your
And the nuclear engineers said but here are
the numbers.
And it was really was a dialogue of the deaf.
And so psychologists got involved to try and
understand what was really
going on in people's risk perceptions.
How do people judge what's worth worrying
about and what's not worth
worrying about.
And one of the key findings is that there
is -- these gaps between
perception and reality are routine.
Routine.
And in fact, sometimes these gaps between
perception and reality open
up into canyons, where the gap between perception
and reality is
enormous, breathtaking.
Give you some examples of these, these canyons
between perception and
reality.
Silicone breast implants. You may remember
-- not many people in this
room will remember, I suspect, because you're
all ridiculously young --
but those of us who are a little bit older,
we remember that in the
early 1990s in North America, wasn't so much
a European phenomena, but
in the North America, there was a great, great
level of concern about
silicone breast implants -- that they cause
connective tissue disease.
In fact, the risk perception was so high that
women believed that the
risk was equivalent to smoking a pack of cigarettes
a day.
If you have implants, you're going to die.
There was actually surprisingly little scientific
information to
support that belief.
Lots of anecdotes, lots of case studies, but
not any really good
science.
Well, in the mid- and late 1990s, the science
started to deliver.
And the science was clear, no.
Doesn't cause connective tissue disease.
And now that's the scientific consensus.
So that's a great example of a huge gap between
perception/reality.
Here's another one.
The Columbine massacre ten years ago.
After the Columbine massacre happened, it
was not only news across the
United States, in Canada, it was news around
the world.
And there was a huge debate, a fierce, fierce
debate, in the United
States about the Columbine massacre and it's
meaning.
The debate wasn't about what's wrong with
kids, right?
What's wrong with the schools?
Everybody knew that there was something wrong
with kids, wrong with the
schools because school violence was soaring
out of control.
The debate was about why, why was school violence
soaring out of
control, okay?
And everybody had their little pet theories
based on their idealogical
assumptions.
They all knew the answer.
And the U.S. Congress asked the U.S. Department
of Justice to do some
proper research on school violence.
You know what it discovered?
It discovered that throughout the 1990s, throughout
the years leading
up the Columbine massacre, school violence
actually wasn't soaring.
It was actually plummeting.
It was doing the exactly the opposite.
That research was bundled into a report, the
report was issued.
And it was completely ignored by the media
and politicians.
It's now an annual report, incidentally.
Every year it comes out and every year it
shows the same things.
School violence is going down and every year
the media and politicians
ignore it.
Here's one that much more European phenomena
-- GM foods .
GM foods and health risk.
There is simply no good evidence that GM foods
are a significant risk
to human health.
If they were, most of North America would
be sick or dying because it's
all we eat.
And yet a very, very significant chunk of
the population of Europe
believes that GM foods will kill you.
Now, I'm mainly going to talk about risks
of injury or disease or death
but this stuff applies to any sort of bad
outcome including financial
risks.
Here's another gap -- the real estate bubble
and home refinancing.
You had a pretty spectacular real estate bubble
here.
United States, they had another one.
United States, one of the great phenomena
was this home refinancing.
I'm going to refinance my mortgage, I'm going
to take that money and
spend it on a monster truck and giant-screen
TV and vacations.
Why is that a good idea?
Because home prices only go up, right?
So this is actually a low-risk move.
Everybody knows home prices only go up.
Bad risk perception.
Okay.
Now, that's at the consumer level.
But we all know that consumers are uneducated
and foolish, so of
course, they're going to think silly things.
But what about those super sophisticated Wall
Street bankers.
They wouldn't make those sorts of mistakes,
would they?
Except that they did.
Mortgage-backed securities.
Well, that's a fantastic investment.
Let's borrow billions of dollars to buy some.
And the world is living with the repercussions
of that disastrous risk
perception.
So how do these enormous gaps between risk
and reality open up?
This slide is my attempt at a -- you know,
wrap-it-all-up, one slide
explanation.
There are three basic factors involved.
And, of course, I don't want to be reductionist.
There are other things going on as well but
I think that this is an
essential feature of what's needed for these
gaps to open up.
Number one, the media.
To nobody's surprise, the media play a role.
Number two, fear marketers, which is simply
my term for individuals and
organizations who have an interest in manipulating
our perceptions of
risk.
Very often it's to promote the idea that we're
at risk, but sometimes
it's actually to diminish the risk, tobacco
companies being the classic
example.
And then, of course, fundamentally what's
going on here is psychology.
It's about human nature. It's about how we
think and that's what most
important, and it's what I'm going to spend
most of them talking about
today.
Now, very quickly, I'm going to run through
these first couple of
points quickly, because you know this stuff,
right?
The fear marketers -- politician market fears
for votes.
Everybody knows this.
I probably don't have to elaborate beyond
saying two words: Bush
Administration.
Officials market fear to expand budgets.
Police chiefs -- it's amazing how often they
describe burgeoning crime
waves shortly before they have to have their
budgets approved by city
counsels.
It's an amazing correlation.
Corporations market fear for sales.
If you perceive yourself to be healthy, you're
not going to buy the
pill, are you?
Right?
So if you're working for a pharmaceutical
company, you don't have to
have an MBA, you don't have to be particularly
bright to figure out
what is necessary to grow the market, right?
Increase the perception of illness.
Same with security companies.
If you perceive yourself to be safe, you're
not going to buy a new home
alarm, right?
So what do you got to do as a security company?
Right.
And NGO's -- NGO's market fear to advance
causes.
NGO's, very often they have better motives
than profit-seeking
corporations but they use the same tactics.
I mentioned breast cancer at the beginning.
In the late 1990s, breast cancer activists
used to -- there's a figure
they always like to promote, very widely cited.
It said, one in eight women will get breast
cancer in her lifetime.
Pretty startling figure, right?
And if you're a woman, it's pretty frightening.
You go, one, two, three, four, right?
Well, what they didn't tell you about that
figure is that for a woman
to be exposed to the full one in eight risk,
she has to be 95-years
old.
I personally hope to be diagnosed with cancer
at the age of 95, because
it will mean that I am alive at the age of
95.
Okay.
The media.
Again, this stuff is pretty obvious, you know
this stuff.
The media's fault.
We emphasize -- and when I say "we," I work
for a newspaper.
That's my day job being a columnist.
I emphasize opinion.
You've noticed I have a few opinions.
We emphasize the vivid, the dramatic, and
the emotional, and so lives
lost to tornados and terrorism, that's front-page
news.
That goes on the evening news.
Lives lost to diabetes and asthma, that's
not news, right?
When was the last time you saw a story about
diabetes killing someone,
right?
And yet diabetes kills more people in a year
than tornados and
terrorism combined will kill in all of human
history.
We're biased toward bad news.
Everybody knows this one, too.
Good news is an oxymoron, right?
Things improve -- not a story.
Things go to hell -- great story.
Another one, we, the media, right?
Man bites dog stories, right?
Dog bites man, that's not a story.
Man bites dog, that's a great story.
Right?
We love novelty.
That's unusual.
That's startling.
Oh, that goes on the front page.
That's routine -- boring, yawn, moving along.
And, of course, these stories are true.
They're all factual but what's the obvious
problem with reporting that
way?
If you constantly report that man bites dog
and you never report that
dog bites man?
Eventually you're going to come up with a
pretty skewed impression of
canine/human relations, aren't you?
We present risk information badly.
Something bad could happen.
How many times have you seen in a story in
the media in which they say
something bad could happen, and you say, oh,
you're right.
That is bad.
I better pay attention.
What do those stories mean?
Nothing.
Something bad could happen.
Means nothing, right?
Right now, it is possible that a jet could
lose power in all its
engines, crash into this building and kill
us all horribly.
It could happen in the next 30 seconds.
Are you concerned?
No, you're not because the probability of
that happening is extremely,
extremely low.
Probability matters.
Pretty basic stuff.
We emphasize, we the media, we emphasize relative
risk not absolute
risk.
Stories are constantly filled with phrases
like "twice the risk."
This is a real New York Times story, by the
way.
In the New York Times it said, women who take
this pill are at twice
the risk of developing potentially fatal blood
clots.
If you're a woman and if you take that pill,
you're probably going to
find that alarming.
Should you?
Answer?
I don't know.
I don't have a clue.
I need to know the absolute risk to know if
the relative risk matters.
If, for instance, I were to tell you that
the possibility -- the
probability of that jet losing power in all
of its engines, crashing
into this building and killing us all horribly
were to double.
Would you be alarmed?
No, you would not be alarmed because two times
almost zero is almost
zero, right?
But if there's a significant risk of developing
those potentially fatal
blood clots, and then you double the risk
by taking this pill, you
should be worried.
You need to know the absolute risk and the
media almost never give you
that information.
We also provide no comparisons to provide
perspective.
Even if you're a numerate person and I tell
you that the risk of some
horrible thing is 1 in 135,000, what does
that mean?
It's pretty tough to grasp, right?
Conceptually, you can get it.
It's probably pretty small.
But if I were to tell you that the risk of
-- your annual risk of dying
in a car crash is 1 in 6,000?
You say, right, I can compare one to the other.
Because we're very good at doing that.
And we want to do that naturally.
And I can realize that's actually an extremely
small risk and I
probably shouldn't worry about it.
Those sorts of comparisons almost never appear
in the media and
fundamentally it's about this, this is the
problem with the media --
lack of critical scrutiny.
We don't examine.
We don't think rigorously.
We pass it along.
If the public thinks something, we agree,
and we pass it along.
Now, everything I've said about the media,
you all know that.
The more interesting question is the explanation
for why the media does
what it does.
Right?
The standard answer is to make money or to
push an agenda, right?
And what's the agenda?
Well, the agenda depends on your own politics.
If you're left wing, the agenda's right wing.
And if you're right wing, the agenda's left
wing.
Have you ever noticed that?
It's pretty remarkable.
I don't deny that idealogy or money, even
more importantly, plays some
role at some times in some venues.
But I think there's something much, much more
fundamental going on in
media's behavior, in the behavior of the media.
It's simply that journalists are human.
Journalists are people.
When you go back and you look at media behavior,
media reporting, and
you analyze it through the lens of psychology,
suddenly it starts to
make sense.
An example -- remember I said there's a bad
news bias in the media, as
everybody knows.
We love bad news.
We ignore good news.
Why?
That's not a media bias, that's a human bias.
There's a huge psychological literature demonstrating
that people are
biased toward bad news.
If I put two pictures up, a frowning face
and a smiling face, your eyes
will be drawn to the frowning face first,
and you will remember the
frowning face longer.
There's all sorts of research to indicate
that.
So the media really are just following human
nature.
Similarly, novelty, we love those man bites
dog stories in the media.
Well, people love novelty.
People love man bites dog stories.
We are very much hardwired towards novelty.
If I show you a list of 30 words, 29 of which
are written in blue ink,
and one of which written in green ink, you
will notice and remember the
one that's written in green ink.
That's just human wiring.
So what's really fundamental here is psychology.
And that's what we have to talk about.
Now, start with the real basics on psychology.
All our feelings and thoughts are a product
of the brain.
No surprise.
But the brain is the product of the environment
of evolutionary
adaptedness.
The environment of evolutionary adaptedness
is a term from evolutionary
psychology.
It simply means the world in which the pressures
of the environment
shape the brain, change the brain, made it
what it is.
What was that environment?
Well, here's the history of our species.
Roughly 200,000 years, there's a great long
line.
And then there's today, that little vertical
line at the end, okay?
The founding of the first town, the rise and
fall of the Roman Empire,
the invention of the printing press, the birth
of Bill Gates,
everything that matters in human history fits
in that vertical line at
the end.
Everything.
That perspective is essential to understanding
your brain.
If you were to write a history of humanity
in proportion to the amount
of time that we have spent at each stage of
development, you'd write
200 pages on hunter/gatherer societies.
200 pages.
You'd have one page for agrarian societies.
You would have one short paragraph of the
world of the last two
centuries.
All of that boils down to one simple point.
We live in the Information Age but our brains
are Stone Age, which is
not an insult.
We often use the term Stone Age as an insult.
That's a mistake.
The human brain is absolutely magnificent.
It's one of the wonders of the universe indisputably.
But it is a fact that it evolved in an environment
radically unlike the
environment in which we live.
And that fact has profound implications.
Now, if you go to a cognitive psychologist
and say, start with the
basics, tell me about how we make decisions,
tell me about how we
decide what to worry about and what not to
worry about.
They'll start with this -- they'll start by
saying, you think you make
decisions by thinking about them, right?
It seems obvious, I think, I come to a conclusion.
There's my conclusion.
It's pretty obvious.
That's an illusion.
There's much, much more going on.
In fact, you have not one mind at work, you
have two minds.
Two systems of thought.
And psychologists, being the clever people
that they are, they have
dubbed these systems of thought system one
and system two.
System one.
System one is the more ancient of the two.
It evolved first.
It operates outside consciousness.
By definition you are not aware of what it's
doing.
It delivers conclusions in the form of feelings,
hunches, intuition.
I asked you about breast cancer at the beginning.
You said, that seems right.
Where did that answer come from?
You had a sense that you knew the answer.
It didn't come from the facts because you
were all wrong.
Except you, okay?
So where did it come from?
It came from this mind.
And it came quickly didn't it, right?
This is the essential feature of the unconscious
mind.
It's fast and it's effortless.
It delivers snap judgments, which is a very
useful tool when you're
walking along the street and a shadow moves
in the alleyway and you've
got to decide what to do.
You can't consult crime statistics; you have
to decide now.
Now because system one is completely forgettable,
I call this "gut."
I call the unconscious mind "gut."
Because that's how we talk about it in ordinary
English.
I have a gut feeling that something is true.
I can't quite explain why.
I just have a sense that this is true -- gut.
Obviously, the other mind, system two, as
psychologists call it is
conscious thought.
Conscious thought is capable of careful reasoning,
numeracy, logic.
Capable, I emphasize.
It delivers conclusions that can be fully
expressed and explained.
If you come to a conclusion by consciously
reasoning your way to that
conclusion and I ask you, how did you get
here?
You can explain it.
You can take me through the steps to the conclusion.
The problem?
It's slow and laborious, right?
Conscious thought takes time and effort -- a
lot of effort.
I call this system "head" to make it more
memorable.
Because that too is how we talk about it in
ordinary English.
If I have a gut feeling something is true
and you think I'm wrong, you
say what?
You say use your head, right?
You may or may not mean that as a simple insult.
If you're being less insulting, you mean it
as hey, stop and think
about this carefully.
Which is to say, stop and think about it consciously.
Now who does what?
How do the two minds interact?
The first important thing to remember is that
we are constantly
bombarded with stimuli.
There's massive amounts of information coming
at us at all times and
the brain is processing it all.
Right now you think you're listening to me
-- I hope you're listening
to me -- but you're doing much, much more,
right?
You are -- for instance, there's ambient sound
in the air.
There's ambient scent in the air.
There's a pattern on the carpet.
Your brain is processing all that information.
And it's shifting through all that information.
And it's deciding, okay, what should consciousness
pay attention to?
Hopefully my words, right?
All the other stuff that you're not pay attention
to, it's processed by
the unconscious mind.
It goes to gut.
Now, it's not an even workload.
Only a very small fraction of the information
processed by your brain
goes towards consciousness.
All the rest goes to the unconscious mind.
You're never aware of how you're handling
it.
Now how do you make a decision out of this
system, out of these two
systems working together, how do you make
a decision?
Well, remember the essential feature of gut
is that it's fast.
And head, its essential feature, one of its
important features is that
it's slow, right?
So that means gut delivers first -- boom.
There's your snap judgment and at that the
point consciously you can
come along and you can examine that conclusion,
and you can say to
yourself okay, that makes perfect sense.
I'll go with it.
Or you can say that's a little off, I'll adjust
it.
Or you can say, that's completely nuts.
I'm going to ignore it.
But will "head" step in and examine "gut,"
the unconscious mind,
examine the conclusions of the unconscious
mind?
That's the critical question.
Here's a way of devising or a test that was
devised as a way of
determining whether in fact head is doing
its work -- whether head is
getting involved.
A bat and ball cost $1.10.
As you can see by the sums of all, this is
the very old question.
A bat and ball cost a total of $1.10.
The bat costs a dollar more than the ball.
How much does the ball cost?
Okay.
If you are like every other human on the planet,
I guarantee that you
read this and you immediately said to yourself
$0.10.
$0.10 -- boom.
You didn't have to think about it.
You just had that snap judgment -- $0.10.
But stop and think now.
If the bat costs a dollar more than the ball,
and the ball cost $0.10,
that means the bat costs $1.10.
$1.10 plus $.10 equals $1.20.
$0.10 is wrong.
Not terribly complicated stuff.
You would catch this mistake if you stopped
and thought about it
consciously.
The question is will you stop and think about
it consciously?
This question and many others like it was
devised by a Nobel Prize
winning psychologist named Daniel Kahneman.
And Kahneman's purpose was twofold.
He wanted to questions to elicit that snap
judgment.
You have a strong and intuitive answer -- yes,
that's the correct
answer.
And then he wanted to know before people say,
yes, my final answer is
$0.10, do they stop and think consciously
about that intuitive
judgment?
Because if they did, they wouldn't say my
final answer is $0.10.
Well Kahneman has found, he has given this
quiz all over the place, in
particular to Ivy League students, so bright
people.
What Kahneman has found is that typically
most people did not catch the
error.
They say final answer $0.10.
In other words, when we have a strong, intuitive
conclusion that
something is true, we just go with it.
We don't stop and examine it.
We don't question it.
That's natural.
That's how we make decisions.
And what that means is gut, your unconscious
mind, is far more
influential in your decision making than you
realize.
And we really better understand how it works.
So how does it work?
How does it deliver?
I mean, here's the critical question about
gut.
How does it deliver snap judgments?
Why is it so much faster than conscious thought?
Well, it's faster because it doesn't serve
a information.
All the information.
It doesn't think about it logically and carefully,
because if it did,
that it would be as slow.
It would be as slow as head, conscious mind.
Instead, it applies hardwire mental processes
to narrow slices of
information, little bits and pieces of information.
Psychologists call these processes heuristics
and biases.
You can think of them as the tool kit, the
tools in gut's tool kit that
it uses for making snap judgments.
There's a long list of the heuristics and
biases that have been
discovered by psychologists.
I'll just mention a few to give you a sense
of how they work.
Here's a simple and very important -- the
availability heuristic.
How easy is it to think of an example of something?
If you want to know how common something is
you say to yourself, can I
think of an example of it?
If you can think of an example of it really
easily, if it comes to mind
quickly, well, it must be common, right?
See how simple that is -- snap judgment.
And if you have to struggle to think of an
example, it doesn't come to
mind easily, well, it must be uncommon.
Simple.
Snap judgment.
The great thing about this rule is that it
worked really, really well
in the environment in which our brains evolved
.
Why?
Why did it work well?
Because the only information available to
our brains at that time was
our own personal experience or the experience
of our fellow band
members, and there's only 30 or 40 or 50 of
them, right?
So if you could very easily think of an example
of a crocodile dragging
somebody to his death at the watering hole,
chances are it happened to
somebody near you and it happened recently.
And you probably should be worried about crocodiles
at the watering
hole, right?
That's an effective rule.
That's going to keep you alive long enough
to reproduce, which is the
critical thing in evolution.
The problem?
We don't live in that world, right?
Our information environment is radically,
radically different.
In large part thanks to, you know, people
who work for Google, I should
emphasize.
Our information environment is just spectacularly
different.
We can have any bit of information anywhere,
any time.
I sit down and turn on the evening news.
What do I see?
Here's a true story, right, and it's a very
typical story.
I turn on the evening news at my home in Ottawa,
Canada, and I see a
story about a boy being abducted, raped, and
murdered by a pedophile in
Leipzig, Germany.
It's a horrible, horrible, horrible story.
It's vivid; it's awful; it's exactly the kind
of story which is going
to be remembered, right?
Now, what do I do with this information?
Well, my rational mind knows perfectly well
that this doesn't tell me
anything about the safety of my children in
Canada.
I know that. It's obvious.
You don't even need to say it, right?
But your unconscious mind doesn't process
the information that way.
Right?
You take your children to the park the next
day.
And you think to yourself, should I watch
out for the pervert in the
bushes?
Is this a significant threat, right?
And what happens?
Your unconscious mind says, well, can I think
of an example of a
stranger abducting, raping, and murdering
a child?
Yes, very, very easily.
You saw it last night.
It's so vivid.
It's so horrible.
Conclusion based on the availability heuristic?
This is common.
Be afraid.
And so what do we have all over the Western
World?
We have parents afraid like never before that
their children are going
to be abducted by strangers.
But guess what?
Stranger abduction is real but it's actually
fantastically rare.
Fantastically rare.
An American child is 26 times more likely
to die in a car crash than to
be abducted by a stranger.
But what are we doing?
We're talking our children and putting them
in cars, and driving them
to school thinking that we're keeping them
safe from the pervert in the
bushes.
That's primitive cognitive wiring at work.
Here's another one.
Representativeness heuristic.
Psychologists have a real talent for coming
up with completely
forgettable names.
It's hard to even say.
The representativeness heuristic.
Again, it's a very simple idea and a very
important one.
Here's a quiz.
Again, this is a Daniel Kahneman quiz.
How likely is it that next year there will
be a flood somewhere in
North America that kills at least 1,000 people?
Kahneman gave this quiz to one group of people.
But in another group he said, how likely is
it that next year in
California there will be an earthquake that
triggers a flood that kills
at least 1,000 people?
Logically, the second scenario has to be less
likely than the first.
You don't have to think about that very hard
to see that it has to be
less likely.
And yet, people consistently judged the second
scenario to be more
likely than the first.
Why is that?
It's pretty bizarre.
Why is it?
Because of the representativeness heuristic.
And it's because of the link between California
and earthquakes.
Nothing says California like earthquakes.
Everybody knows that California and earthquakes
go together.
Earthquakes are a typical event for California.
And it's that typicality is triggering your
unconscious mind.
Your unconscious mind say hey, hey this is
typical, this fits.
And it judges that whole scenario by that
the typical component rather
than thinking about it logically.
Saying, well, it's a conditional event followed
by another conditional
event.
Oh geez, that's pretty unlikely.
Our minds are filled with these notions of
typicality.
We get them from experience we get from the
culture.
Basketball players are what?
Tall.
I just had to say basketball player and you
immediately see a tall man.
And so what's happening is that the unconscious
mind is using this
storehouse of information to judge probabilities,
which can often work.
But in certain scenarios like this, it really
goes wrong.
The implications of this?
When something typical is involved, intuition,
the unconscious mind, is
likely it overwhelm logic and data.
You're likely to make a conclusion which is
wrong and silly.
Scenarios.
In corporate world, scenarios are very, very
popular.
Right?
We're going to imagine what could happen in
the future.
And when you write scenarios, what do you
do?
You make them very complicated and vivid and
detailed.
This happened and that happened and this connects
to that and so on.
And people think that scenarios provide a
lot of insight.
Oh, that helps us understand what's going
to happen.
Well, that seems probable, right, that makes
sense.
But here's the thing: Because the scenario
is more complicated is more
likely to have one of these typical components
than is a scenario
that's less complicated.
Your unconscious mind is likely to grab onto
that and say, oh, the more
complicated scenario that's the more plausible
one.
Yeah, that's going to happen.
And yet, if you think about it logically,
in most cases, it's the less
complicated scenario that's actually more
likely.
So scenarios are profoundly misleading if
you're not careful in how you
use them.
The affect heuristic, again another forgettable
term.
Affect is simply psychology's for emotion,
feeling.
Now everybody knows that emotions can influence
decisions.
If you're feeling strong anger, that can sway
your decision making.
You know that if you're angry at Bob and you're
thinking about firing
Bob, you should probably go home and sleep
on it first.
We all know this.
Obvious.
But what psychologists have found in the last
several decades is that
emotion operates much, much, much more subtly
than that.
In fact, emotion is so subtle that we can
actually experience it
unconsciously.
And we routinely do experience emotions unconsciously.
You're experiencing the emotion; you don't
know you are.
You don't feel anything.
If I asked you, you'd say I'm cool as a cucumber.
But you are experiencing an emotion.
Now, because emotion is so much subtler than
we're aware of, that means
that it's influencing perceptions and judgments
much more profoundly
than we realize.
Emotions -- when it comes to risk, it's very
simple. Again it's a nice
simple rule.
Emotions drive the perception of risk.
If you have a good feeling about something,
oh, that can't be
dangerous, right?
If you have a good feeling, it drives the
perception of risk down.
If you have a bad feeling, oh, that drives
the perception of risk up.
Now in a lot of cases, that's going to make
sense.
That's going to work.
But for instance, my father and my grandfather
both smoke pipe, a pipe
right?
So when I smell pipe tobacco, what do I feel?
I feel the warm fuzzies.
I get a positive emotional surge from this.
Oh, I love the smell of pipe tobacco smoke.
What is that going to do to my risk perception?
It's going to drive it down.
That doesn't make sense.
There's all sorts of things and all sorts
of ways in which this
emotional yardstick as a decision-making tool
can go wrong.
One of the most important implications of
the affect heuristic and the
role of emotion in decision making is that
language is powerful.
It's far more powerful than people realize.
Researchers -- I love this quiz because it's
kind of silly.
Researchers brought together some people and
they said we're doing
consumer product research.
And the consumer product that we're looking
at is ground beef.
And here is a lump of ground beef.
Would you please examine it visually, judge
it, then taste it, and
judge it again.
The only difference is they said to one group
of people -- they said
this is 25 percent lean-cooked ground beef.
Go ahead and judge it.
To the other group, they said, this is 75
percent lean-cooked ground
beef-- sorry.
25 percent fat was the first group.
25 percent fat cooked ground beef versus cooked
ground beef.
It's exactly the same information, isn't it?
And guess what happened?
Right.
The ground beef that was described as 75 percent
lean was judged to be
significantly superior in quality than the
other.
Why?
Because lean is good; fat is bad.
It's that simple.
Here's another one.
This, by the way, this study was actually
conducted with psychiatrists,
clinical psychiatrists, so people who are
trained in statistics and
scientific reasoning.
They were given a profile of a patient.
And they were told in the profile that this
patient, if he is released
that 20 percent of patients like him would
be expected to commit a
crime of violence if released.
And so after reading this profile they were
asked, would you release
this mental patient from incarceration in
a mental hospital?
The other group of psychiatrists was given
exactly the same information
except the phrase about his dangerousness
was altered very subtly.
It was altered so that it said 20 out of 100
patients like this man
would be expected to commit a crime of violence
if released.
Will you release this patient?
Obviously, that's exactly the same information.
20 percent versus 20 out of 100 patients.
It's exactly the same information.
And yet in the first case, when it was 20
percent of patients, the
refusal rate -- the rate at which people said
no, I would not release
this man -- was 19 percent.
In the second case, when the language said
20 out of 100 patients, the
refusal rate was 40 percent.
That's a 100 percent increase in the rate
of refusal based on a trivial
change in the language.
Why?
How could this possibly be?
The answer is the affect heuristic.
The language in the first case said 20 percent
of patients.
20 percent.
What's a percent?
It's a concept, right?
It's an abstraction.
It doesn't have emotional content.
20 out of 100 patients.
Okay.
What's that?
That's patients; it's people.
And in this case, the person is plunging a
knife into somebody's heart.
That's bad.
It has emotional content.
And it's that emotional content that drove
the decision, that drove the
perception of risk and drove the decision.
Here's another one.
Researchers went to an airport and they asked
some people, you're
traveling now, how much would you pay for
life insurance against death
caused by terrorism?
And they went to other people and they said,
how much would you pay for
life insurance by death caused by any cause,
right?
Now, logically you know what the answer should
be.
And you know by now what the actual outcome
is.
People were prepared to pay a lot more for
life insurance against death
caused by terrorism.
Again, doesn't make any sense.
Until you examine the role of emotion in human
decision making.
And then it makes perfect sense.
What's all causes?
Again, it's an abstraction.
It -- it's a concept.
It doesn't have emotion content.
What's terrorism?
As soon as the say the word, you have images
in your mind.
That's not an abstraction.
It's real.
And it's filled with emotion.
Bad emotion.
That emotion is used to judge the perception
of risk.
It drives the perception of risk.
And that perception of risk changes the decision.
You're going to pay a lot more for that because
that's bad.
Here's another one.
This one's absolutely critical.
If you remember absolutely nothing else from
this talk, please remember
this because this is the enemy of rationality.
Confirmation bias.
Once we believe something for any reason,
we will seek to confirm it.
Evidence that supports our belief will be
embraced without question.
Evidence that disputes the belief will be
scrutinized, belittled, or
ignored.
Far more often, it will simply be ignored,
right?
And by the way, I would point out that Google
and -- I love Google. I
use Google about a hundred times a day -- I
would point out that Google
actually empowers confirmation bias.
Because once you believe something, you go
to Google, you type in
keywords for what you believe, and sure enough,
somewhere on planet
earth, someone has evidence that you're right.
Oh, I knew it all along.
But what you don't do is you don't go into
Google, and you don't type
in keywords about what you don't believe,
and so you don't get the
information that indicates that you were wrong.
Really interesting study that demonstrated
the power of confirmation
bias.
In 1979, it's 1979 in the United States, researchers
brought together a
group of people who had strong feelings about
capital punishment.
And one half of the group -- it was deliberately
composed this way:
One half of the group believed that capital
punishment was an effective
deterrent against crime.
Capital punishment worked.
The other half believed that capital punishment
did not deter crime.
Capital punishment does not work.
At the start of the test, they examined, they
asked people, well, tell
me how strongly do you believe that this is
true?
Then they gave them information.
They gave them an essay, and the essay was
composed of information
drawn from a couple of studies.
And the studies were contradictory.
One study said capital punishment works; one
study said it doesn't.
The studies used similar methodologies.
In fact, the studies were bogus.
They were crafted by the researchers to be
mirror images of one
another.
Except that one study said it worked; one
study said it doesn't.
Now if we process information logically, what
should happen at the end
of this?
It should be a wash.
You come in and leave with exactly the same
belief, right?
It's not what happened.
Everybody left more convinced that they were
right and the other guy
was wrong.
Why?
How is this possible?
Because when they read the information and
they came across the
information that supported their prior belief,
they grabbed onto it and
said uh-huh, yeah, knew it all along.
This just supports what I already believed.
But the other information, the stuff that
contradicted it, oh, it's
methodologically flawed.
I don't like what they're doing here with
the data and it was
dismissed.
And so everybody left even more strongly convinced
that they were right
and the other guy was wrong.
I've mainly been dealing with cognitive psychology.
Obviously social psychology is huge in this
stuff.
Which of these lines is longest?
If you've ever taken Psych 101, you know this
is a classic experiment
from about 60 years ago.
There's a row of five people.
First person -- which of these lines is longest?
And the first person says line five.
That's obviously wrong.
You're looking at it and you're rubbing your
eyes, and you're thinking
well, no, line four is longest.
What are you talking about?
They go to the next person -- which of these
lines is the longest?
Line five.
Which is the lines is longest?
Well, of course, that's a set-up.
You're the test subject.
And the real purpose of this test is to determine
whether you will go
with the false group consensus in a circumstance
where it's absolutely
clear what the right answer is, and all these
people are wrong.
In those circumstances, one-third go with
the false group consensus.
And that's when it's absolutely clear what
the right answer is.
When the answer is actually uncertain, it
was four out of five, simply
went with the group.
So we're social animals.
We're very much inclined to adopt the positions
of others.
We want to agree.
Now, these sorts of experiments are often
criticized by saying, well,
this is an artificial environment.
It's a university lab and it doesn't really
matter -- this decision
doesn't really matter.
If people were dealing with something that
actually mattered, they
wouldn't be so cavalier.
They wouldn't just toss away their own opinion
and go with the group.
There was a very interesting experiment, which
I won't detail, but it's
in my book in which researchers tested that.
They made people believe that there was real
consequence to their
decision.
And they wanted to know under those circumstances,
would people go with
the false group consensus as readily?
In fact, they were more likely to conform
than before.
And they were more likely to be confident
that their false group
judgment was right.
Group polarization very quickly, group polarization
is very simple.
If I take a number of people who share a belief,
but they share it in
it varying degrees, some believe it mildly,
some believe it very
strongly.
And you bring them together and you put them
down at a table and you
have them talk about their belief, you might
think that their opinion
is going to coalesce around the average.
It doesn't.
It actually coalesces around a much more radical
position.
And what this means very simply is that getting
together with
like-minded folks is a great way to radicalize
opinions.
Now, take a few of these concepts and put
them together.
Allen convinces Betty, which persuades Carl,
which settles it for
Deborah.
That's confirmation -- I'm sorry. That's conformity.
They now believe something.
And once they believe something, they're going
to start screening
something in the biased fashion.
That's confirmation bias.
Well, now they're very concerned.
They're going to form groups.
They're going to get together and talk about
this.
And when that happens, they're going to become
even more sure of
themselves.
That's group polarization.
And now you have a whole bunch of people who
are really strongly
convinced of something.
Well, that's going to convince more people.
That's conformity.
See what's happening here?
You got a closed loop.
This is sometimes called a cascade, an information
cascade.
And it's possible that it can go from ten
people to a hundred people to
a thousand to million people, to the point
where you have even, you
know, an entire country that believes something
that's not true.
But will it?
Fortunately, this doesn't always happen with
false beliefs.
Will this happen?
Will this information cascade get going?
Well, in large part it's dependent upon the
role of these other
players.
The media.
Do you media get uninvolved?
Do the media pick up on the fact that there's
a growing number of
people who are concerned and then they start
going and looking for
information that supports that belief -- because
the media are subject
to confirmation bias like the rest of us -- they'll
start reporting
that information.
And that information, yeah, because it supports
the belief, it will
strengthen the psychological factors at work.
And now you have stronger psychological factors
at work.
You have the media on the case.
They're talking about the subject.
What does that do?
Fear marketers get involved.
They say, hey, here's our opportunity and
they start pumping up the
noise.
And once they start pumping up the noise,
what does that do?
It strengthens the psychology and it encourages
the media to do more
reporting because, well, it's a public issue
now because all these
people are talking about it.
Again, you have a closed loop.
It goes around and around and around.
And it can continue to spiral to the point
where everybody believes
something that simply not true.
How can we make better decisions about risk?
Well, here's one possibility.
Eliminate human judgment.
Leave it to computers and algorithms.
It's probably popular in this room.
In fact, engineers always love this.
I spoke to a group of nuclear engineers not
too long ago and they
applauded.
And you know, algorithms and computers, they
often work.
They're terrific.
Terrific stuff.
Problem is that they often don't work.
Wall Street had lots of algorithms.
Fantastic algorithms written by brilliant
people and we all know what
happened then.
Algorithms, ultimately, are the product of
human judgments.
That's what went wrong on Wall Street.
The human judgments that went into the construction
of the algorithms
was flawed and so the algorithms were flawed,
and the world exploded.
So ultimately you cannot eliminate human judgment
from this scheme.
So what are you going to do about it?
How are you going to improve human judgment?
Well, first thing you have to understand is
to understand the
systematic flaws in the information environment.
And I emphasize systematic.
It's not random it's not haphazard; it's systematic.
And recognize that there are many individuals
and organizations that
have an interest in your risk perception and
they will seek to
influence it.
We have to learn basic psychology.
It's amazing how -- I've dealt with corporate
CEOs, minsters, deputy
ministers, very important people whose decisions
really matter.
Really matter to other people's lives.
And a lot of them never heard of any of the
stuff I've talked about
today, even though it's basic cognitive and
social psychology.
I find that a little frightening.
Basic psychology is elementary education.
If your decisions matter, you should know
it.
And you have to remember that all the stuff
I've talked about today, it
applies to highly-educated, smart people,
right?
In fact, a lot of the research that I've discussed
today was done with
highly-educated, smart people.
Where psychologists demonstrated that they're
subject to the same
psychological foibles as everybody else.
Now, people get that in the abstract, right?
Okay, this applies to everybody not just the
dummies.
Everybody, right?
It's a human thing.
But not me, of course.
Right?
When you examine your own decisions, you look
at -- you say, no, I'm
being objective.
I see the world objectively and I've made
this decision on the basis of
rationality.
That's how to seems to you.
You understand that psychology matters in
human decision making to
those other people, but not this decision,
not my decision.
Psychologists have term for that.
It's called bias bias.
It's the one and only memorable psychological
term.
Bias bias.
Doctors were asked about free gifts from pharmaceutical
companies.
Do free gifts from pharmaceuticals influence
the judgment of doctors?
A large majority of doctors said, yes, absolutely
they do.
Doctors were asked, do free gifts from pharmaceutical
companies
influence your judgment?
A large majority of doctors said absolutely
not.
Okay?
There's a problem there and that's bias bias.
It's very, very hard for us to overcome the
notion that we are
objective and rational uniquely among the
human race.
Here's an example worth following.
George Soros, I'm a big fan of George Soros
for a particular and very
geeky reason.
It's not just that he's rich.
It's not just that he's been right so often.
It's this: Earlier this year, he was asked
by the Financial Times the
question which everybody would like to ask
George Soros.
George, why are you so good?
Why are you so rich?
Why have you been right so often?
Don't forget George Soros, you know, he said,
real estate bubble.
He said big problems with the financial industry.
And so in February 2009 when this interview
was conducted he was
looking pretty good.
He was perfectly entitled to say, why am I
right so often?
It's because I'm smarter than everybody else.
But he didn't say that.
This is his answer -- he said, I know that
I am bound to be wrong and
therefore am more likely to correct my own
mistakes.
If you have ever read anything written by
George Soros, you know that
this is classic George Soros.
George Soros has spent a lot of time thinking
about thinking.
Thinking about his own thinking.
He's a deeply introspective man.
And that is the secret to his success.
Psychologists have a term for thinking about
thinking.
It's called metacognition.
Thinking about thinking.
Consciously being aware of your own thoughts.
Ultimately, that's the real and only defense
to these psychological
foibles to which we are all subject.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you very much, Dan.
That was very interesting.
I think we've got time for a very quick Q&A.
Questions, if anybody has one.
[PAUSE]
Oh, sorry.
>>[INAUDIBLE]
DAN GARDNER: I would broaden that.
Risk assessment to too narrow.
Ultimately, it's about critical thinking.
Good risk assessment comes from critical thinking.
And no, they're not being taught critical
thinking.
They're a lot of good folks who are trying
but it's not particularly
happening.
And that's the worrisome point.
If you look at the mistakes that are made
in the media, in the public
about public issues, very often it's just
elementary reasoning would
catch these mistakes.
But unfortunately that elementary reasoning
is not as widespread was we
might like.
>> So that actually sort of covered the question
I was going to ask.
But I guess, well, you spoke really, really
briefly about, about
Google.
I think with regards to how by giving more
information we can make
[INAUDIBLE]
I believe it was confirmation bias, I think
you said.
So do you have any other comments about how
Google relates to risk
perceptions, some of the things that maybe
we can do as a company to
make that work more in our favor as opposed
to against us?
DAN GARDNER: And by the -- well, first of
all I should begin by saying
I love information technology.
It's terrific and it has blessed human society
in countless ways which
I don't describe because they're not germane
to my book.
But there are downsides like every technology
since the invention of
fire.
There are downsides to that technology.
And I frankly don't know what the solutions
are.
Because if you look at, particularly the way
online information works,
the way it allows people to self-select information,
to group together,
to confirm what they believe, to radicalize,
all this basic psychology,
and then you apply it to information technology
-- it all looks like
it's putting our psychological foibles on
steroids, right?
You go to political blogs, and what are political
blogs except massive
demonstrations of confirmation bias and group
polarization.
It's really quite depressing sometimes to
see.
Are there solutions?
You know, I don't know, to be honest.
I have to -- the beginning of wisdom is the
admission of ignorance.
And the answer is I don't know.
But I do really wish the smart folks who work
at Google would actually
consider this problem.
Because as wonderful as the information technology
is, it has its
downside, as I said like every technology
since the beginning -- since
the invention of fire.
This is not a slight against information technology
and it would be
terrific if we were to discuss that further.
>>[INAUDIBLE]
DAN GARDNER: Do I see any way out of
billions of years of evolution?
I mean, well, the brain that we have is the
brain that we have.
That's not going to change.
The information technology that we have is
the information technology
is that we have and that's not going to change
because we all love it.
So what can we do to at least minimize some
of the deleterious side
effects?
Partly I would say teaching critical reasoning,
which is not so
difficult.
It has to be an essential part of every educational
system.
Basic psychology.
Psychology is treated as some sort of fluff.
Some sort of trivial bird program.
I don't know in North American universities,
very often, you know, if
you want to improve your grade point average,
you take psychology.
That trivialization has to stop.
Cognitive psychology is the foundation of
how we make decisions.
And if how we make decisions is important,
and I think it is, then we
have to know something about it.
It would be terrific if, for instance, high
schools were to teach
really, really basic, cognitive psychology.
It doesn't take a lot.
I just spent an hour here, and I took you
through, well, several years
of, you know, an undergraduate course in cognitive
psychology.
If would be really terrific if people were
introduced to that.
So you know, I don't want to be too terribly
pessimistic.
I think we can be constructive.
>> I think we'll have to leave it there.
So thank you very much Dan Gardner.
[APPLAUSE]
Not for Official Transcript Production
Educational Use Only